[Music]
well so we've always had an attention
economy whether it was on radio or
television there's always been a race
for our attention and it's a zero-sum
game if one TV station gets more of your
attention the other TV station gets less
but now because we're spending more and
more time on screens and there's so many
things competing for our attention we
really feel it and on the attention
economy with social media and with the
internet and our screens everything
needs your attention
so a meditation app the New York Times
big Fink or Facebook they're still all
competing for the same currency which is
attention and if one guy gets more
attention someone else gets less as an
example the CEO of Netflix recently said
that the biggest competitors to Netflix
weren't other video sites he said the
biggest competitors to Netflix were
Facebook YouTube and sleep because at
the end of the day it all comes from
this limited supply of attention that we
get and so what and part of that is
because of advertising because the
business model of advertising says I
don't just want some of your attention I
actually make more money the more
attention I get from you
so I actually want I have an unbounded
appetite for more of your attention and
the problem is that as each after in the
attention economy whether it's a
meditation app or it's a snapchat or its
Facebook or Netflix they start
ratcheting up more and more persuasive
design choices to stick us to the
product for longer and to keep us coming
back to addictive even and the problem
is it becomes this race to the bottom
where the the lower I go on the brain
stem at getting you to come to to click
and stay the lower someone else has to
go so when YouTube ads autoplay the next
video the Netflix has to autoplay the
next video too otherwise they lose out
on their attention market share and so
in this zero-sum game what we really
need to talk about is how do we
reorganize the attention economy so it
actually aligns with what we want
almost like redesigning the urban plan
of a city it's not about leaving this
looted city it's how can we reorganize
the city till it's livable again how do
we create zoning laws so that you know
Netflix competes with other
entertainment for how do I help you know
each of us get the best two hours of
downtime you know and that's different
than medication apps that are competing
for you know how to help people wake up
in the morning imagine that those are
different zones both in app stores and
on our phones so that it's really about
helping us competing to help us live our
lives not competing just to get the most
attention so why should we be
questioning advertising this is such a
huge deal because advertising has up
until this point propped up much of the
tech industry's economy it's the the
cheapest and easiest way to grow and
scale a business because you can always
figure out new ways of getting attention
and you can find new ways of getting
more money per eyeball that spends time
with you but the cost of it are really
just too big because in a world where
I've got your eyeball and I'm Facebook
and I've got actually a billion of these
eyeballs and I'm asking who wants to pay
me the most to put a message in front of
this eyeball and in a world where I give
that person personal information that
would tell them exactly how to persuade
this person and they can persuade them
with anything they want because they
know exactly for example with companies
like Cambridge analytics which know
exactly how to persuade you politically
I would be enabling whoever wants to pay
me the most to nip you late and
influence this person's mind and in a
world that's more and more persuasive
well we know more and more about what
influences this person the ability to
simply sell to the highest bidder
whoever's whoever wants to persuade them
undermine something really fundamental
about what all of our institutions are
based on you know a market is based on a
person making a conscious choice to you
know buy or transact when you can
undermine or manipulate the thoughts and
attitudes and beliefs of that person
then that's really not something
something we can stand on anymore in an
election where people have their own
thoughts opinions beliefs and ideas
about a candidate or about a policy or
not even just about how much
hate each other and that can be
manipulated then the foundation of an
election or democracy is also
questionable and so in a world that's
more and more persuasive it's more about
persuasion than it is about advertising
what is the efficacy of all that we want
to live into in a world that is on a
one-way track getting better and better
at persuading our minds to believe feel
and have different opinions than we
would have had because it can
personalize exactly and tailor exactly
messages that would sway us how do we
live in that world when so much of our
institutions depend on us having
sovereign minds and sovereign ideas and
the ability to democratically talk to
each other about what the right answer
might be so we need to question the
business model of advertising in the way
that it affects that that economy
[Music]
you